[موسيقى]
الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم في برنامجكم الشارع
الدبلوماسي الذين يركزوا فيه ثانيه هذا
الشهر على ملف السودان بثلاثه لقاءات
حصريه نبداها مع ثمان باور رئيسه الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه والتي قامت
بزياره تشاد التاسع عشر من مايو الجاري
للوقوف على اوضاع اللاجئين السودانيين في
مخيمات تشاد بعد عبورهم للحدود هربا من
ويلات النزاع المسلحه في بلادهم اما
الموقف السياسي واحتمالاته رجال الحلي
للنزاع السوداني
فسنناقشه مع البروفيسور محمد حسن ولدبات
المستشاري الاول لرئيس المفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي
وكبير الموظفين ونختتم المسيره بلقاء مع
عبده دينك منسق الامم المتحده الانسانيه
المقيمه في السودان بالوكاله للوقوف على
اخر المستجدات في الاوضاع الانسانيه
المترديه نتيجه النزاع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدين الكرام الوكاله الامريكيه لتنميه
الدوليه هي وكاله حكوميه تابعه للبيت
الابيض والفرع التنفيذي في الحكومه
الامريكيه
وتختص بالتنميه الدوليه والمساعده في
الكوارث والازمات الانسانيه من خلال
الشراكات والاستثمارات لانقاذ الارواح
وخفض نسبه الفقر ودعم الحوكمه الديمقراطيه
الوكاله فيها اكثر من عشره الاف موظف
منتشرين في جميع انحاء العالم
وبميزانيه تفوق تسعه واربعين مليار دولار
لعام 20 23
مما يجعله اكبر وكاله الانسانيه في العالم
ويوجد لديها عده مشاريع انسانيه في اكثر
من عشر دول عربيه
ويسرنا الان ان نجلس عبر الاثير من واشنطن
مع مديره هذه الوكاله منذ عام 2021
السفيره السابقه للولايات المتحده في
الامم المتحده ثمانيه التي عادت هذا
الاسبوع من زياره لمخيمات اللاجئين
السودانيين في تشاد
[موسيقى]
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
يسعدني ان اكون معكم اود ان اسهل الحديث
بسؤالك في عن رحله الى تشاد في التاسع عشر
من مايو حيث سافرت الى العاصمه جميله ومن
هناك توجهت الى ابيشي
ومن ثم الى معسكر اللاجئين في غاغا الواقع
في شرقه شادو حيث قابلت هناك اللاجئين
السودانيين الذين عبروا الحدود في الامر
الاخيره ورصته الاستجابه الانسانيه
للاحتياجات العاجله الناجمه عن الازمه
المستمره في السودان
نعلم ان اكثر من 60 الف لاجئ سوداني جلهم
من النساء والاطفال قد تدفقوا عبر الحدود
في تشاد منذ اندلاع الاعمال العدائيه في
السودان في الخامس عشر من ابريل بحثا عن
الامانه التي تعد واحده من بين الدول
العالم الخمس الاكثر فقرا كما جاء في
تقرير الامم المتحده الثانويه على التنميه
البشريه هل يمكنك ان تطلعينا ومشاهدينا
حول ما شاهدتيه هناك شكرا جزيلا على
السؤال
لا يمكننا ان ننسى ما يحدث داخل السودان
او اثاري تدفق اللاجئين السودانيين الى
البلدان المجاوره ان الوضع فرشاد كما لك
ان تتخيل قاتم للغايه وخاصه عندما يتعلق
الامر بالمناطق الحدوديه فهي اعراض قاحله
شاسعه ومن اكبر المخاوف التي تساور الامم
المتحده والعاملون في المجال الانساني
الاخرون هو ان موسم الاوتار على وشك ان
يبدا في غضون خمس اسابيع
وحينها ستصبح احتمالات الجلب السودانيين
الى تشاد
من مسافات بعيده عبر الحدود وصولا الى بر
الامان هذا الاحتمال يتضاءل كثيرا
اللاجئون الذين قابلتهم
ووصلوا عبر الحدود قبل اسبوعين ثم تم
نقلهم من قبل الامم المتحده الى داخل
البلاد بحيث لا تتم مطاردتهم من قبل
الجنجوي او قوات الدعم السريع او اي
ميليشيا اخرى داخل السودان
لقد سردوا لي قصصا عن افراد الاسره الذين
تخلفوا عن ركب وتركوهم وراهم وجميع
اللاجئين بضع عشرات منهم فلم تكن هذه
رحلتهم الاولى الى تشاد في دوامات العنف
السابقه التي بدات مع الاباده الجماعيه في
دار فور عام 2003 2004 وصولا الى عمليات
القتل الاخيره التي حدثت منذ ثلاثه واربع
سنوات لجاوا الى تشاد وكانوا يعودون الى
موطنهم ومجتمعاتهم عندما كانوا يعتقدون ان
ظروف الامان مواتيه وفي هذه الحاله اشار
الى ان السودان لن ينعم في الامان في اي
وقت فنحن سوف نبقى في مكاننا لكنهم قالوا
ان افراد اسرتهم يريدون الحضور ايضا لكنهم
يخشون من عدم وجود مؤنث كافيه في المخيمات
في تشاد وهذه مساله نسعى في الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه لمعجزتها وضمان
وجود طعام وماوى الاشخاص الذين يصلون الى
بلد فقير مثل تشاد ومن ثم قاموا بوصف
المنشيه السودانيه التي تصطف على الحدود
وتحاول ابتزاز الاشخاص الذين كانوا
يحاولون العبور ولم يكن لدى العديد من
افراد اسرهم المال ما يجعلونهم قادرين
تقديم الرشا من اجل شق طريق عبر الحدود
هذه المساله سوف تصبح موضع للمحادثات في
جدوى لاحقه مع القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوه الدعم السري ان الامر هو فظيع جدا
انتم لا تقاتلون بعضكم البعض فحسب وتاخذون
بلادكم الى اتون ازمه انسانيه مروعه في
الظل قتل المدنيين بل حتى لا تسمحون للناس
عن لكي يغادروا فضلا اقواتكم التي اسند
اليهم اسلوب الضبط الامن يعق المغادره
وبالنسبه لاولئك الذين فروا الى تشاد الان
المؤن المتوفره واعلنت عن 130 مليون دولار
اضافيه كدعم الانسانيه لجمع البلدان
المجاوره بما في ذلك 17 مليون دولار التي
سوف تساعده في الشراء بعض الخيام والطعام
وبعض المستلزمات الصحيه التي تحتاجها
العائلات والامهات الحوامل فثمت ام لديها
طفل اصيب بالحمل لمده 22 يوما وكانت يائسه
في العثور على الرعايه الطبيه وامراه اخرى
فقعت عينها من قبل احد
الجنجويد وكانت تبحث لمعرفه اذا ما كانت
سوف تستعد بصره الامر ينطوي على مزيج من
الكاميرا الناجح عن النزوح ونقص الامدادات
الصحيه والعنف المباشره مره اخرى بصفتنا
الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه لابد
لنا العمل مع جهات مانحه اخرى من توفر
المؤن ولكن في نفس الوقت علينا ايضا ان
ندرك ان الحل الوحيد لهذه الازمه
الانسانيه الخطيره هو حل سياسي وان تعمل
لقوات السودانيه المسلحه وقوات دعم الصراع
السريع على القاء اسلحتهم وايجاد طريقا
سياسيه للموضوع قدما من شانها ان تعود في
النهايه بالسلطه الى المدنيين ما قلته
ياخذني بالذاكره الى رحلتي عندما رافقت
كوفي عدنان عام 2004 الى ابيشي لرؤيه
المخيمات اللاجئين من دارفور حيث شاهدنا
بعض المخيمات داخل حدود السودان بالقرب من
حدود تشاد
ويبدو ان صوره لم تتغير مع مر كل هذه
السنوات تسعه تسعه عشر العشرين الماضيه من
المحزن سماع جدا
فقط اردت ان اقول ان مقابله تلك الاسر
التي عاشت قصص النزوح المتكرره واتفقوا مع
كفر راي هنا بانها مساله تقشعر لها
الابدان ومؤلمه لانهم كانوا يبنون حياه
جديده وبداوا بحرف جديده ويزرعون الاراضي
رغم نزوحهم بعيدا عن ديارهم ومع الانتقال
المدني الذي حدث منذ وضع سنوات ولعب فيه
الاتحاد الافريقي دور الوسط كان لديهم امل
للمره الاولى بالعمل على بناء حياه دائمه
في السودان والان اصبح كل شيء في مهب
الريح نظر الاقدام الجنود منقله طرفين
متقل على شان هجمه ضد المدنيه
وفقا للممثل الخاص للامين العام للامم
المتحده فوق من بعثه الامم المتحده
المتكامله لدعم المرحله الانتقاليه في
السودان لم يتوقف القتال في السودان حتى
اليوم منذ تاريخ 15 ابريل رغم الهدن
السبعه التي تم ترتيبها والتوقيع عليها
واخر هدنه بدات يوم في يوم في وقت متاخر
من ليله الاثنين
بمساعده الولايات المتحده والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتم انشائي اليه للرصد
عن بعد للمره الاولى
وهناك ما يزيد عن 16 مليون شخص يعتمدون
على المساعده حتى قبل اندلاع القتال في
الخامس عشر من ابريل وقد ارتفع هذا العدد
بواقع 60% ليبلغ اكثر من اربعه وعشرين
مليون شخصا بحاجه الى المساعده في هذا
الاسبوع وقالت الولايات المتحده انها سوف
تخصص يوم مبلغ 245 مليون دولار مقابل
الدعم الاضافي الى السودان والدول
المجاوره المتاثره بالصراع وبذلك يصل
اجمالي التزام المساعدات الانسانيه
الى السودان والدول المجاوره مثل السودان
ومصر
الى
880 مليون دولار في العام 2023 هل سيكون
هناك المزيد من المساعدات القادمه من
الولايات المتحده السدون الى الاستدامه
كما تقتضي الظروف
لا داعي للقول ان هناك مطالبات مهوله على
الموارد الانسانيه في الوقت الحالي اذا
نظرت الى ظروف الانسانيه في افغانستان في
القرن الافريقي
والذي عانى الامرين واعتقدوا انهم يعيشان
الان الموسم السادس على التوالي دون هطول
امطار
واعمل بان تتحسن الاوضاع ولكن علينا
استثمار موارد هائله لتفادي شبح مجاعه
كامله والرساله التي اعلم ان المفاوضين
يرسلونها في جده في جده الان هي ان هذا
الصراع لابد له ان يسدل اوزاره لا يوجد
امدادات لا تنضب من المساعدات الانسانيه
التي يجب تقديمها الى الاشخاص المحتاجين
رغم ان نتمنى لو كانت ذلك لابد من وجود
مخرج كما تعلمون جنوب السودان كان احد
البلدان الرئيسيه المتلقيه للمساعدات
الانسانيه وفي مصر سابقا المعذره في
السودان كان قبل هذا النزاع كان لدينا
مليون شخص يعتمدون على المساعده الانسانيه
انظر الى افريقيا الوسطى الى اثيوبيا
وازمه التجاري التي شهدت في النهايه توقفا
في العمل العدائيه لكن لا يزال لديك اشخاص
لم يتمكنوا من زراعه البذورهم ولن يكون
بمقدورهم
لان الصراع السهله اقتصادهم مره اخرى
عندما يكون الصلاه جديدا نسبيا وهذا يعتمد
على تورته القديمه ويندلعوا كما قلت
بتاريخ 15 ابريل
واذا انتشرت رقده وكنت ترى فرار 60 70 80
الف شخص الى سوف يصبح الرقم مضاعفا خمس
مرات اذا كان الشيء نفسه صحيحا في اثيوبيا
في مصر في جنوب السودان فان الخسائر التي
سوف يتحملها اولئك المدنيون الكبير على
تلك المجتمعات
التي كانت ترحب بطريقه يصعب وتصديقها سوف
تكون كبيره رغم عزه عن تقديم الكثير
ولديها ما يكفيها من احتياجاتها الخاصه
ناهيك عن كونها بانها هي نفسها تعتمد على
المساعدات بسبب تغير الم او الصراع في
اماكن مثل الجنوب السودان او اريتريا انت
تعلم ان النظام لم يعد مقدوره تحمل تراكم
الصراعات دون معالجه لذا مره اخرى لابد من
دعم السلام في اثيوبيا وهنا تكمن اهميه
المحادثات السياسيه بين القاده الذين
يتوجب عليهم في النهايه ان يضعوا رفاهيه
شعبهم اولا هذه اجابه طويله على سؤالك لكن
بطبيعه الحال سوف ننظر دائما بمساله
الاحتياجات والاحتياجات الشديده ونحن نريد
ونفخر بكوننا اول مستجيبا واكبر مالحا
انساني في العالم وسوف نفعل كلا لكن تجدر
الاشاره ايضا بالمانحين الاخرين بما في
ذلك المنحون غير التقليديين من منطقه
الشرق الاوسط والخليج وغيرها فقد هبوا
للمساعده نظرا لان الاحتياجات في الوقت
الحالي تتجاوز ما يستطيع بلد واحد او اي
تجمع تقليدي من المرحين الوفاء به
هل لدينا ضمانات من الدول الخمس لابقاء
حدودها مفتوحه للاجئين السودانيين
اعتقد ان هذه الدبلوماسيه نقوم بها كل يوم
بالتاكيد التقيت مع رئيس الدابه في تشادو
يمكنه التحدث شخصيا عن ذلك فقد اوضح تماما
انهم كما فعلوا في الماضي سوف يبقون حدود
بلادهم مفتوحه وهذا لا يشمل فقط السماح
للمنظمات الانسانيه ان تؤسس موقعنا
لعملياتها ناهيك عن كرم العائلات شاديه
اعتقد اننا سوف نرى ذلك في جميع انحاء
المنطقه هل الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه
الدوليه موجوده على ارض الواقع في السودان
ودول المحيطه من اجل تقديم المساعده ام
انكم تدعمون بصوره اساسيه وكانت الامم
المتحده والشركاء الانسانيين الاخرين
الموجودين ولديهم بنيه تحتيه الاثنين معا
نوعا ما من الواضح اننا قمنا باجلاء
الموظفين امريكيين
وسهلنا ايضا اجلاء العديد من الموظفي
الوكاله السوداني
لكن لا يزال لدى السفاره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه موظفون محليون يعملون هناك
وكانوا مصدر عون في تعزيز الاتصالات في
سياق تعزيز المساعين لتعديل البرامج نحن
نعمل بصوره اساسيه من خلال الشركاء
المرفضين الذين
يؤدي موظفون السودان تابعين لهم عملا
بطوليا في الوقت الحالي فاظهر قدرا في
الشجاعه
قدرا من الشجاعه في الوصول الى الاشخاص
المعرضين وتزويدهم بالخدمات الطبيه ناهيكم
على المعارضه عن عن مساله البيروقراطيه في
السودان التي باتت متاصله وهي امر شائن
لابد من تامين تاشيرات للحصول عليها من
مكان اخر ونقل مساعده الانسان سوف تكون
موضع نقاش في جده
هناك ما يقرب من
843 الف شخص ناجح داخليا في السودان
النازحون من يساعده هؤلاء الاشخاص من
ال130 مليون دولار التي اعلنت اعلنت عنها
الو على سبيل المثال سوف يخصصه خمسين
مليون دولار منها الى داخل السودان كما
ذكرت هناك بعض الشركاء المنفذين هم من
اكبر شراء الكنائن مثل برنامج الغذاء
العالمي لكن النبذه وخساره جهدنا ايضا
للعثور على منظمته محليه سودانيه التي
يمكن دعمها ونعلم انها لجان المقاومه التي
ظهرت بشان الانتقال المدني في المقام
الاول نشطه في مجال الاعمال للتطوعي لدعم
بعض هؤلاء المزحين لكنها مجموعه سكانيه
يجب ان يعرفها شركائنا على الارض والتعرف
على احتياجاتهم المحدوده لانهم عانوا
معانوه من العنف الجنسي والعنف القائم على
نوع الجلد هل لانه لم يعد بمقدوره من
الوصول الى مستشفى وعياده لان الاخيره
كانت مدمره وبات الان عليهم التحول الى
منظمه غير حكوميه للحصول على بعض الدعم
الطبيه او الطعام او الماء كل شخص قابلته
في حياتي من النازحين كان يرغب بالعوده
الى موطنه ولكن في العديد من الحالات قد
تكون منازلهم قد دمرت وقد يكون هذا ما بهم
للرحيل او لعل هناك بعض الانتماءات
السياسيه المحتمله لذلك نحن بحاجه لمعرفه
تلك المجموعه السكانيه وهذا ما يسعى
شركائنا على الارض البالغ عددهم تسعه
وعشرين
ان خطه الامم المتحده للاستجابه الانسانيه
التي تبلغ قيمتها ثلاثه مليارات دولار
تتطلبوا زياده هذا الاموال هل ستندهشين
اذا ما ابلغتك ان خطه الاستجابه مموله حتى
21 مايو فقط بنسبه
12.4% فقط لماذا تعتقدين ان التمويل منخفض
جدا
من باب الانصاف ان عدد الاحتياجات في جميع
انحاء العالم باتا غير مسبوق كليا عدد
النازحين حول العالم غير مسبوق منذ عهده
هتلر والحرب العالميه الثانيه عدد
النزاعات التي تحدث حول العالم غير مسبوق
منذ نهايه الحرب البارده لذا اعتقد ان
الدول المانحه تكافح من اجل الحصول على
ميزانيه ثابته وتحديد كيفيه تخصيصها
بطريقه تصل الى الاشخاص المحتاجين بافضل
ما يمكن هل يفاجئك اذا ما قلت لك ان معظم
الجهامه المنحه قد زادت فعلا من ميزانيتها
الانسانيه وحتى الان بالنسبه لمعظم
الاشخاص الذين يعيشون في ظروف صعبه في
جنوب السودان وسوريا والصومال وفي
افغانستان فانهم يشعرون ان الميزانيات
اصبحت اصغر وهذا يعزى فقط لازدياد
الصراعات وزياده وزياده عدد الاشخاص الذين
باتوا يعتمدون على الخدمات التي يجب ان
تقدم اصلا مثل قدره البحث عن عمل او ما
يجب بتوفيره من خلال الخدمات الاجتماعيه
من قبل الح ولكن في العديد من الحالات
بسبب الكورات الطبيعيه او بسبب فشل
الحكومات النزاع في تامين تلك الاحتياجات
الممثل الخاص للامير عمروم المتحده فولكرز
من من باتت الامم المتحده المتكامله للدعم
المرحله الانتقاليه في السودان عبر عن
بالغ قلق قلق وذكر في مجلس الامن في هذا
الاسبوع بان الصراع قد اصبح له صبغه
طائفيه بين العرب ضد الافارقه كما حدث في
دارفور في العام 2003
و204 و2005 الا يعرق في هذا الامر بكل
تاكيد ليس تاريخي هذا العنف فحسب ولكن مره
اخرى من الافراد الذين قابلتهم
في شرقيه تشاد سمعنا نفس الروايات التي
سردت علينا منذ 20 عاما عندما قد ظهر
العنف المدفوع باسباب عرقيه ضد القبائل
الافريقيه بصوره اساسيه لذا كلما استمر
ذلك اصبحت مخاطر انتشاره اكبر داخل
السودان
وزادت عمليته استهداف في السكان بدوافع
عرضيه
لكن الى جنب ذلك يجب ان اشير الى حجم
اعمال
الجرائم واللصوصيه لقد شاهدت بعض التقارير
في الاسبوع القليل الماضيه التي تحدثت عن
قيام شخص باحراق مصنع يقوموا بتصنيع
المواد الغذائيه العلاجيه المخصصه للاطفال
الذين يعانون من سوء التغذيه الشديده
هؤلاء الاطفال الذين يمكن للمرء ان يتخيل
انهم ينتظرون كان هناك منتج معجزه من
المواد الغذائيه العلاجيه الجاهزه وكان
المصنع موجودا لكن بعد اضرار النار فيه
حرم ما يصل الى اربعه عشر الف من الاطفال
المصابين بشده من هذا الطعم العلاجي وكان
يمكن انقاذ حياتهم بفضل ذلك المنتج لولا
حرق وتدمير المكان اذن تقع المسؤوليه
المطلقه في انهاء هذا الصراع
على عاتق الزعيمين العسكريين الذين انزلقه
في اتون هذا العنف بين الفصائل وفي ذات
الوقت فان مخاطر ما ذكرته حول
العوده الى فضائل عمليه الاستهداف
المدفوعه باسباب عرقيه ومخاطر انعدام
لسياده القانون وسائل جميع السرقه بقوه
السلاح كلما طالته ايديهم فهذا عالم
سوف يدمر الحياه المدنيه في السودان ولد
يجب ان تنجح هذه المحادثات ويتعين على
الاطراف التصالح وضحي ووضع مصلحه الشعب في
المقام الاول سؤال واحد الاخير سريعا عن
سوريا عايشنا الازمه السوريه
منذ عام 2011 وما بعدها وكنت هنا في الامم
المتحده تابعينا الامر خطوه بخطوه يوما
بعد يوم والان بعد ان عادت سوريا الى
الجامعه العربيه كيف تنظرين الى امكانيه
العمل مع الحكومه اللبنانيه
لان النصف السكان في لبنان الان
هم من اللاجئين السوريين هناك بالطرف في
الاردن وفي تركيا وفي بلدان اخرى لكن
لبنان يواجهوا تحديات شديده على المستوى
السياسي والاقتصادي الم يحن الوقت للاسره
الدوليه والمنظمات الدوليه لكي تعمل مع
الحكومه اللبنانيه وربما مع الحكومه
السوريه
لبدء الحديث
عوده منظمه وامنه للاجيل الى مواطنهم الى
وطنهم وعوده والطوعيه العلي اضيف كل تاكيد
حسنا اولا ساقول ما تعرفه سلفا وهو ان
الولايات المتحده لا تعتقد ان سوريا تستحق
اعاده قبولها في الجامعه العربيه
نحن لسنا في مجال تطوير العلاقات مع الاسد
ولا نعتقد ان النظام الاسد قد اتخذ
الخطوات اللازمه لضمان هذا النوع من
الاعتراف والقبول ومع ذلك اننا نعلم ان
اعضاء الجامعه العربيه قد قالوا انهم
يعتزمون اشراك الحكومه السوريه على امل ان
هذا سوف
يحرز تقدما وشيكا اعتقد مره اخرى انه تمت
اسباب وبناء على سنوات عديده من مراقبه من
نظام الاسد تدفع للتشكيك كنت في لبنان منذ
فتره ليست بعيده واجتمعت بعض هؤلاء
اللاجئين اعلم جيدا الكرم الذي اظهره
لبنان ازاء اللاجئين سوريين اعتقد انك
ذكرت الكلمه الجوهريه وهي العوده الطبيعيه
فمن النادر جدا ان تجد لاجئين سوريين
في اي بلد
يتحدثون بطريقه تنم عن الحماس للعوده الى
بلدهم لان السبب لرحيلهم هو اما ان بيوتهم
مدمره او تعرضت للقسط او يشعرون بانهم
مستهدفين سياسيا وهنا تكمن مشكله عدم
احراز اي تقدم مع نظام الاسد وعدم الاقرار
بالجرائم ومسائله المرتكبي فضائح الحرب
وافلاتهم من العقائب وهذه مساله لا تبعث
لا تبعثوا باشاره مرحبه من قبل الناس
الذين تم استهدافهم سابقا وتحمل
المسؤوليه اننا نواصل عمل مع الحكومه
اللبنانيه ونعمل ان يكون هناك تقدم سياسي
في لبنان الذي يواجه تحدياته الخاصه بمعزل
عن مشكلته ايواء وتوفير منازل لعدد كبير
من السوريين لكن بصوره اساسيه فان موقفنا
من علاقاتنا مع لبنان
فهي علاقه ثنائيه قويه ونحن بصفتنا
الوكاله الامريكيه لتنميه نستثمر في
اقتصاد لبنان وفي انتقاله الى الطاقه
النظيفه
وقد قدمنا مساعدات امن غذائيه ليس
للسوريين فحسب بل الى اللبنانيين ايضا
الذين
تضرروا بشده جراء غزو قوت الاوكرانيا
واستيراد لبنان لكميات كبيره من القمح من
اوكرانيا وروسيا
وسوف نستمر بتقديم ذلك الدعم واعتقد انه
من المهم جدا ان تلتزم جميع البلدان
بسياسه العوده الطبيعيه القائمه على
الظروف او قد ينتهي بك الامر مره اخرى
بمعامله سيئه لاي افراد تتم اعادتهم وهي
مساله لا نرغب بحدوثها شكرا جزيلا لك
مديره الوكاله الامريكيه لتنميه الدوليه
نشكرك على منحنا الوقت للجلوس معنا
ومشاطرتنا افكارك المستنيره والاهم ذلك
نود ان اشكرك على اعمالكم الانسانيه التي
تقومون بها في منطقتنا وفي بقيه انحاء
العالم شكرا جزيلا شكرا طلال يسعدني ان
اراك مجددا شكرا
محمد الحسن والرباد كبير الموظفين مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي وهي المنظمه التي يعول
السودانيون عليها ومنظمه ايجاد الافريقيه
للتوصل الى حل سلمي لازمتهم كل هذا ولكن
بعد فاصل اعلانيون قصير
فلا تذهبوا بعيدا
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم من جديد يسرون
الان ان نستضيف عبر الاثير من مقر الاتحاد
الافريقي من اديس ابابا
البروفيسور محمد الحسن والزبات مدير
الديوان رئيس المفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
[موسيقى]
البروفيسور محمد الحسن ولد نبات مديره
الرئيسي المفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
والناطق الرسمي للاتحاد في ملف السودان
اهلا وسهلا بك على شاشه العربيه
مساء الخير
ابدا بالسؤال سبعه اتفاقات لوقف اطلاق
النار لم تكلل بنجاح كبير بين الاطراف
المتقاتله في السودان كان اخرها الاثنين
الماضي بواسطه سعوديه امريكيه وتشمل اليه
مراقبه عن بعد في وقف اطلاق النار هل
تعتقد ان هذه الاليه ستزيد من فرص التزام
الاطراف بهذا الاتفاق الاخير المقرر له
سبعه ايام فقط قابله للتجديد من المفروض
ان تفضي هذه
الهدنه الى احسن من سابقاتها ولكن فعلا
نلاحظ منذ ان اصبحت نافذه المفعول ان
الاقتتال في مناطق
متعدده خاصه في العاصمه ما تزال متواصله
ولكن الجهود من طرف الوسيطين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبدعم
من
كثير من مكونات المجتمع الدولي ما تزال
متواصله ليرجع
الطرفان الى رشدهما ويقبل بها وطبعا هي
ايضا لها لجنه مراقبه وننتظر ماذا ستقول
هذه من لجنه المراقبه هذه التي المفروض ان
تكون تشكلت امس من ثلاثه من
الوسطين ومن ثلاثه من كل واحد من الطرفين
سنرى ما يستقوله هذه لجنه المتابعه نعم
مجلس السلامي والابن التابع للاتحاد
الافريقي وضع اسس عوده السجاد الى
العمليات الانتقاليه من خلال خطه مكونه من
ست نقاط للتهدئه في اجتماعي في الثاني من
مايو بينما التحدث بانكول الجيوي مفوض
للاتحاد الافريقي للشؤون السياسيه هذا
الاثنين الماضي في مجلس الامن الدولي وقال
بالحرف الواحد اذا المشاورات جاريه من اجل
تفعيل عوده السودان للعمليه الانتقاليه هل
لك ان تلقي لنا ببعض الضوء على ما يحدث في
هذا الصدد والى اين وصلنا
في هذا الصدد اؤكد ما قاله المفوض امام
مجلس الامن الدولي باننا عاكفون على سلسله
من الاجراءات ستكون ان شاء الله في يوم او
اثنين جاهزه
خريطه الطريق لمقاربه التطورات الجديده
للازمه السودانيه ولكن اريد ان اؤكد على
نقاط اساسيه النقطه الاولى في هذه الامور
بهذا الامر هو ان
القرار النهائي فيه لا يرجع الى الاتحاد
الافريقي ولا لاي مكون من المكونات
المنظومه الدوريه انما القرار النهائي هو
قرار
السوداني السودانيون انفسهم
العسكريين منهم والمدنيين وفي هذا الصدد
نحن نؤكد على ضروره ظهور دور المكون
المدني من مختلف الاتجاهات سواء كان يؤيد
هذا الطرف وذلك لا يعنينا ولكن كل الاقرار
لاننا نرى ان اللحن اللحظه التلاقي للامه
كلها من اجل وقف الدمار هذه نقطه اولى
النقطه الثانيه
فيما نحن عاكبنا اليه ايضا هو توحيد
المنظومه الدوليه لان تعدد المقاربات بدل
ان يسهل الحل سواء كانت
وساطه او سواء كان عون او دعم الى اخره
تعددها لا يعين في الحبل بل يعقده يعقده
وضعا هو في حد ذاته معقد سلفا النقطه
الثالثه النقطه الثالثه
وهي مهمه جدا هو انه نحن لا نعتقد انه
سيكون هنالك اي حل عسكريين للعزم الذين
يحلمون بايجاد ناصر عسكري لهذا الطرف
هذا وهم وهذا ما اكد عليه رئيس المفوضيه
يوم 19 من الجاري امام القمه العربيه
المنعقده في جده وبالتالي نحن نحث كل
الاطراف
المدنيه والعسكريه في السودان ونقول ذلك
للمنظومه الدوليه وان نجمع راينا على
المعارضه الشديده لمواصله الحرب والدمار
وحرم الناس من حقوقها المدنيه
وضياع واتلاف المجتمع السوداني والرجوع
الى الحوار الوطني الشامل الذي لا يعرفه
اقصاء من اجل الترتيب لاعاده لاعاده مسار
الانتقاليه المدنيه
مجلس السلامه الامن السلام والامن التابع
للاتحاد الافريقي حذر وبقوه من اي تدخل
خارجي في السودان
اين نحن الان من جهود الوصلات الافريقيه
بشكل عام للتواصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار مبدا ثابت للمنظمه القريه وهو ربطنا
لكل التدخلات الاجنبيه في ايه ازمه سواء
ايا كان
ومهما كانت في اي بلد كانت لان التدخلات
الاجنبيه في تجربتنا ليست فقط اعتداء على
سياده ذلك البلد ومحاوله السلبي شعبه
ارادته ولكنها في نفس الوقت وعنصر تعقيد
كبير لان احد محددات الازمان الازمات في
افريقيا وهي كبيره ولا اريد ان اذيرها
نقاشا اكاديميا في هذا المجال واحده من
ابرز هذه المحددات هو التدخلات الاجنبيه
بالشغل الافريقي وبالتالي فنحن نركز على
عسر اخر وهو حل الازمات الافريقيه من طرف
العقول والابهام الافريقيه وهذا ينطبق على
السودان ويقول لك شيء انا مارست الوساطه
بين الاطراف السودانيه سنه 2019 قد يذكروا
لنا كلمه بذلك هو ليست هنالك يجمع عليها
السودانيون مثل اجماعهم على نبذهم
للتدخلات الاجنبيه وكلما اتهموا الطرفا
معينا بانه يتدخل في شؤونهم وانهم يشجع
هذا الطرف ضد اطراف اخرى ويدعم هذا الطرف
ضد اطراف اخرى كان مقتوم عليه نعم
هل هناك خطه للاتحاد الافريقي تشكيل تحالف
دولي متماسك من اجل تحقيق السلامه في
السودان من خلال وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
توصيل المساعدات الانسانيه اللازمه
واستئناف العمليه السياسيه الانتقاليه
الباطل يبدو انك مطلع جدا نحن عاكفون على
تاسيس هذه الكتله الدوليه
وبداناها عشرين ابريل 5 ايام فقط بعد
اندلاعي الصراع العسكري دعا رئيس المفوضيه
سيد موسى فتحي محمد الاجتماعي حضره الامين
العام المتحده وحضره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي وحضرته وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
وحضره عده وزراء خارجيه من من مصر حضره
وزير مصر وزير خارجيه اثيوبيا الحضاره
الاولى عده وزراء خارجيه ورؤساء منظمات
الدوليه حضره الامين العام للجامعه
العربيه السيد كثير من الناس
اجتمعت افتراضيا بذلك الاجتماع
وتلاه اجتماع ثاني وقررت ان تعمل سويا معا
متضامنه واعيد الاجتماع اخر على مستوى
السفراء مندوبين الدائمين لدى الاتحاد
الافريقي هنا في هذه الصبابه في الثاني من
مايو
وحالما ينتهي اجتماع مجلس الامن والسلم
الافريقي بعد غد سيكون لهذه الكتله اجتماع
جديد
للبث في خريطه الطريق سيتقدم بها الاتحاد
الافريقي ان شاء الله
قمتم كما تفضلت انتم شخصيا بقياده عمليه
وساطه ناجحه في السودان في اعقاب ثوره عام
2019 والتي ادت بدورها للاتفاقيه
الانتقاليه واتفاق الجوفا لعام 2020
بينما رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي
افريقي موسى فقي محمد الذي زار السودان
الخمسه مرات في السنوات الاخيره وتوجت
جهوده
بالدبلوماسيه للاتحاد بالنجاح في السودان
والقاره الافريقيه في عديد من المرات
لماذا فشلت الجود الافريقيه حتى هذه
اللحظه لاحراز وقف لاطلاق النار الذي ناشد
به به مجلس السلام والامن في السادس عشر
من ابريل
شكرا على
للاشاره السريعه على ما حصلت سنه 2019
والدور اللي قام به الاتحاد الافريقي خاصه
رئيس مغادره الاتحاد الافريقي لاننا نحن
نعمل تحت توصياته
وتعليماته ولكن اقول لك
هذه الدرجه التي وصلت اليها الاحداث
في
السودان لم تصلها بتاريخ رغم
ديمومه العنف فيها وفي مناطق كثيره منها
وبالتالي في الرجوع الى الصواب والعدول عن
الشفط يتطلب مزيدا من الجهود مزيدا من
المنهجيه بالجهود ومزيدا من الصبر ايضا
لانه اقول لك شغله ولا اريد ان تتخذ عذرا
في تمديد الصراع لان الصراع حتى اذا تمدد
بيوم او ساعات فهو مضر جدا جدا ولكن
في كل مسلسل للصراع حياته هو يبدا ثم ينضج
ثم يضمحله وبالتالي كونك تحاول ان ترجع
الى الوضعيه السابقه لاندلاعه بهذه السرعه
الاوتوماتيكيه امر في الغالب مستحيل ولكن
انشطه ومقاربات الحل لا يجوز ايضا ان
تنتظر الى ان ينضج
الصراع يجب ان تواكبه منذ البدايه وهذا ما
قمنا به واملنا كبير جدا الايام القادمه
سنتوصل الى ان يحترم وقف اطلاق النار وان
الرشد سيعود وان المسلسل السياسي سياخذ
مساره الى الظهور سؤال الاخير رئيس
الوزراء السابق عبدالله حمدوك قال ان
الحرب الحاليه في البلاد تهدد بان تكون
اسوا من حرب سوريا او اليمن هل توافق هذا
الراي وهل هناك احتمالات ان تصبح هذه
الحرب على اسس عراقيه كما حدث في دارفور
عام 2043
قلت
مرات عديده وكررت
ان الوضع في السودان حتى لما
وقعنا على اتفاقيه المرحله الانتقاليه سنه
قابل للتطورات خطيره
ما لم تكن هنالك نهضه قوميه تتسامع على كل
اشكال ومظاهر ضعف الانسان والقاده في هذا
البلد وبالتالي فقول رئيس الوزراء السابق
هو قول وارد تماما وهذا ما يدفع كل الناس
للسودان واصدقائهم بالعالم بان يسارعوا في
ايقاف هذا الدمار لانه قد يتطور الى اسود
بالنسبه للسودان وبالنسبه لغير السودان من
الدول المجاوره خاصه ان في دول كثيره فيها
شاشه كبيره جدا انا لا ارى انه ما عدا
دولتين تقريبا
في ان تقاوم
تبشي الفوضى في هذه المنطقه
لسابع القادمه
محمد الحسن ولدبات مدير ديوان رئيس
المفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي والناطق الرسمي
للاتحاد في ملف السودان نشكرك على هذا
اللقاء ونتمنى لك كل التوفيق في جهودك
الراميه الى استباب السلام في السودان
شكرا جزيلا
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
مشاهدينا الكرام نركزوا في الفقره القادمه
على الاوضاع الانسانيه المترديه يوما بعد
يوم في السودان من خلال الجلوس مع عبده
جندي نسق الامم المتحده الانسانيه المقيمه
بالوكاله وذلك لمناقشه التحديات الانسانيه
الجمه في السودان ولكن بعد فاصل اعلانيا
قصير فلا تذهبوا بعيدا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم ثانيه
يسرنا في ختام مسيرتنا في الشارع
الدبلوماسي ان نستضيف عبر الاثير من
بورسودان عبده دينك منسق الامم المتحده
الانسانيه المقيمه بالوكاله
[موسيقى]
منسق الامم المتحده الانساني المقيم
بالوكاله في السودان
نرحب بكم في قناه العربيه يا سيدي شكرا
جزيلا
الاخيره التي تم التوصل اليها بوساطه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده
والتي دخلت الى حيز التنفيذ في عشيه
الثاني والعشرين من شهر مايو سوف تكون
مخترنا هذه المره بلجنه مشتركه بين
الاحزاب بهدف متابعه اي انتهاكات محتمله
واليه الرقابه وستضم اللجنه المكونه من 12
شخصا ثلاثه ممثلين من الى الطرفين
المتحاربين وثلاثه اطراف من الولايات
المتحده وثلاثه من السعوديه ماذا تستطيع
اخبارنا به عن اليه المراقبه هذه للهدنه
المحدده بسبعه ايام
اولا رفعت منسوب الامل والتفاؤل كثيرا
فهذه المره الاولى منذ اندلاع القتال قبل
خمسه اسابيع
الذي يتم التي يتم فيها التوقيع على وقف
لاطلاق النار بين الاطراف المتحاربه تحت
اشراف السعوديه والولايات المتحده
وما نطمح لرؤيته هو ان اليه الرصد التي
سيتم العمل بها سوف تساعد على رصد كافه
الانتهاكات المتعلقه بوقف اطلاق النار
وعلى وجه التحديد جميع الانتهاكات
المرتبطه
باي عمليه تسليم مساعدات انسانيه
وقد طلب منا الابلاغ عن اي عراقيل قد تحدث
خلال فتره اسبوع ونامل
ان يفضي ذلك بقدره الوصول الى السكان
المحتاجين
بصوره واقعيه كان هي حجم المساعدات التي
يمكن توزيعها للناس المحتاجين خلال هدنه
مدتها سبعه ايام
التقديرات التي توصلنا اليها حتى اللحظه
تشير الى انه في حاله عدم وجود اي عرقين
سوف نستطيع الوصول الى 4 مليون شخص خلال
الاسبوع القادم ولكن هل ما تزال صامته حتى
الان
ما تم ابلاغنا تم ابلاغنا به اليوم عن
وجود انتهاكات في الخرطوم تم رصدها
لذا لا استطيع ان اقول انها صامده لكننا
نامل انها سوف تصمت خلال الاسبوع القادم
الحكومه السودانيه خصصت مدينه
السودان
في الولايات الشماليه لتلقي المساعده في
حين سوف يتم التوزيع من قبل وكالاتي
ومنظمات الامم المتحده هل هذه التجربه
تجدي نفعا
الترديد الترتيبات تسير على ما يرام حتى
الان فقد تلقينا مساعدات كثيره حتى اللحظه
عبر ميناء بورسودان في البحر الاحمر
وايضا عبر مطار بورسودان
هناك مطارات اخرى مفتوحه لكن في الفتره
الحاليه ومن منظور لوجستي
لو استمرت الامور على هذا المنوال نعتقد
اننا سوف
نستلم جميع المؤن عبر ميناء بورسودان وعبر
مطار بورسودان
نشدت الحكومه السودانيه المجتمع الدولي
ووكالات الامم المتحده
والمنظمات الدوليه بالاضافه الى الجهات
المانيحه لتقديم المساعده الانسانيه كيف
تنظرون الى المبادره السودانيه
والمناشده وهل تضاهي المناشدات الانسانيه
الاخرى الامم المتحده كلا لا تضاهيها
فالاحتياجات تفوق قدره تحمل اي شريك بعينه
واعتقد ان تمت حاجه جماعيه لجلب المساعدات
الى السودان واستطيع ان اقول بان المناشد
الدوليه
التي تغطي الاحتياجات التي طالبت بها
الامم المتحده والمنظمات غير الحكوميه
الدوليه تقدر قيمتها
باثنين فاصل سته مليار دولار خلال الاشهر
السته المقبله تذكروا انه في شهر يناير
كانت هناك مناشده قيمتها 1.7 مليار دولار
والاحتياجات الاضافيه تبلغ حوالي 800
مليون
اضافيه لتغطيه احتياجات السكان اي حوالي
18 مليون خلال الاجر السته القادمه
ماذا بوسعك ان تخبرنا اياه عن الممرات
الامنه لتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه التي
التزمت بها الحكومه السودانيه
هذا ما طلبنا به بانه يجب فتح جميع
الممرات للسماح بالمرور الامن للامدادات
بالاضافه الى التواصل العامله هناك حتى
تتحرك بحريه وهذا شرط اساسي للوصول الى 4
مليون شخص اننا مستعدون وسوف تبدا العمليه
قريبا ونتوقع من كل طرف
ان يحترم التزاماته بالسماح في ابقاء هذه
الممرات مفتوحه بحيث يتم تدفق المساعدات
الى الاشخاص المستفيدين منها
كيف تستعد الامم المتحده لموسم الامطار
المتوقع في غضون خمس الى ست اسابيع
هذا يمثل احد التحديات الكبيره لان موسم
الامطار سوف يبدا في شهر يونيو
وبالنسبه لهؤلاء السكان الذين بصوره
اساسيه يعملون في مجال الزراعه فانه للاسف
سوف يتوجب عليهم ان يعتمدوا على المساعدات
خلال
السنه المقبله وحتى موعد الحصاد المقبل
ونحن نعمل من خلال شركائنا
ومنظمتنا ومنظمات اخرى مثل الذراع والغذاء
التي تعمل قصار جهدها لمساعدتها هؤلاء
المزارعين في تامين البذور والسماد
ومساعدتهم على
الحصادي في الاماكن في المناطق الممكنه
في ظل عدم تمكن الوكالات الاغاثه من
الوصول الى العاصمه
فقد وقع عبء وتوزيع المساعدات الطبيه
والغذاء والوقود في المنطقه في الخرطوم
على عاتقي المجموعات المحليه هل تدعم
الامم المتحده هذه المجموعات المجموعات
المحليه وهل تقوم باداء عملها
نعم اليوم وبغيت الوصول الى السكان في
الخرطوم اننا بحاجه للعمل مع المجموعات
المحليه التي كانت حتى اللحظه فعاله ونشط
للغايه والان ومع وقف اطلاق النار نعتقد
انه فضلا عما تقوم به تلك المنظمات
المحليه
فان الامم المتحده سوف تقوم بمؤازرتها
ودعمها ولا بدلي ان اقول ان قدره الوصول
الى الخرطوم تنطوي على تحديات كبيره ولكن
عندما ذكرت اربعه
هذه
الارض هذه عدد الاشخاص فان جلهم في
الخرطوم ومره اخرى في حاله عدم وجود سوف
يكون الوصول الى الخرطوم السيد عبده دينك
منسق الامم المتحده الانساني المقيم في
السودان بالوكاله نشكركم على وجهه نظركم
وعلى جهودكم لدعم الشعب السوداني شكرا
جزيلا
الحاج وفريق الشارع الدبلوماسي في نيويورك
ودبي
نستودعكم وحتى نلتقيكم ثانيه نترككم في
امان الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات